can you guess what the third largest
automaker in the world is
volkswagen gm daimler while those are
all great guesses and would usually be
correct we're not living in normal times
last week the third most valued
automaker in the world was actually
ravian
[Music]
electric vehicle maker rivian opened
with a share price that valued at around
91 billion dollars vivian peaked at a
valuation of 150 billion dollars which
is more than volkswagen volkswagen
generally delivers a cold 10 million
cars per year considering this how many
cars do you think rivian delivers 8
million 5 million
well the answer is actually a whopping
156 pickup trucks
now i don't want to bag on rivian
because they worked super hard on their
pickup truck over the past decade and
they've had to cross so many hurdles to
get to market moreover they actually
have a great working product unlike some
other notable competitors
so there's nothing wrong with the
company rivien but there's no doubt that
there's something seriously screwed up
with this stock rivian so here's the
story of riven and how they became the
epitome of the eevee bubble
taking a look back when rivien was
founded in 2009 most people didn't
really care about evs
evs were completely impractical due to
their low range and high cost hybrids
were starting to pick up steam but this
was only in what most would consider the
nerd community so rivien didn't
particularly have a bright outlook out
the gate but that didn't stop a man
named robert scarange or rj from taking
the risk anyway
at the time rj was only 26 years old and
he had spent his whole adult life in
academia rj had a bachelor's in
mechanical engineering from renzola
polytechnic institute and a phd in
mechanical engineering from mit
but instead of continuing on in the
regular path and getting a job after
graduation archie returned to his home
state of florida and founded mainstream
motors some sources say that rj came up
with the capital himself but this is not
true
i mean just think about it he spent the
vast majority of his adult life in
academia
now i'm sure that rj put in every penny
he had but most of the money for initial
development actually came from the
florida government you see rj's father
roberts karen senior was a business
owner himself who ran a company called
mainstream engineering i think you can
see where rj got the name mainstream
motors from but anyway his father had
managed to raise 61 million over 25
years all from the us government so his
father was well aware of how to raise
money and given that the u.s government
was looking to support evie endeavors rj
was able to secure a small grant of 2
million
given that he was building a car from
scratch though this really didn't last
that long
rj ended up spending 900 thousand
dollars on payroll 170 000 on
contractors and the rest was presumably
spent on materials and manufacturing by
2011 rj had burned through all the money
but at least he had something to show
for it mainstream motors had created an
electric sports car called the r1 but
there was a massive problem which was
the tesla roadster rj's sports car
wasn't bad by any means but the roadster
was already on the road and it didn't
make sense to compete against tesla in
an already niche market
i'm not sure why rj didn't realize this
when he started the project as tesla was
delivering roadster since 2008 but he
did eventually make this realization and
he would decide to scrap the entire idea
now i'm sure people are going to comment
down below that ravine is considering
bringing back this car today so it
wasn't a waste but in 2011 the revival
of this car was by no means a guarantee
so rj was back to ground zero
[Music]
determined to change the direction of
the company rj looked at what ev
competitors weren't targeting and the
obvious answer was suvs and pickup
trucks rj also decided to change the
name of the company to rivien which was
derived from indian river he combined
the first part of river and the last
part of indian rj had spent a lot of his
childhood in a row boat on the indian
river in florida hence the name
anyway rj had a new target and a new
name but he was still lacking the
biggest part which was new funding for
rj though this wasn't that hard to
secure the source of rivie's 2012
funding effort isn't clear but it was
likely the government again or some
venture capitalists would like to keep a
low profile
over the next couple of years rivian
hired a bunch of talent from legacy
automakers like ford gm and chrysler and
by the end of 2016 they had grown to 100
employees
this is still relatively small but given
that basically all of these guys were
engineers earning six figures it wasn't
cheap to run rivian
even if we just assume a hundred
thousand dollars per year per person
we're looking at 10 million annually on
just payroll and keep in mind riven
still had no revenue coming in in the
meantime ravion was also investing
heavily into manufacturing plants for
example in january of 2017 rivian
acquired a manufacturing plant from
mitsubishi for 16 million dollars soon
enough raven revealed their pickup truck
android suv originally called the a1t
and the a1c at the la auto show in
november of 2018.
unlike the cyber truck reveal which left
the audience divided the a1t and a1c
were exactly what the audience wanted
from a distance they looked just like
traditional vehicles but up close they
had that futuristic electric style and
that's what made all the difference
rivien was slowly getting ready to
launch their first vehicle but the last
step of bringing the product to market
would take way longer and cost way more
than anybody expected fortunately for
rivien though investors with massive
pockets would enter the scene after this
reveal
up until this point riven had primarily
raised money in the tens of millions but
it didn't take long for them to cross
into the hundreds of millions in may of
2018 rivian took on 200 million worth of
debt from standard chartered bank which
increased the total raised funds to a
whopping 450 million dollars despite
raising nearly half a billion dollars
the general public still wasn't that
interested in evs as the price was still
way out of reach for most people but all
of this would change with the launch of
the tesla model 3 in 2017. while the
tesla model 3 was a promising idea from
the start many big players weren't
convinced that tesla would actually be
able to execute on the idea
and this was an absolutely fair
assessment given that tesla would go to
production held in 2018. tesla played
with the bankruptcy line several times
this year and there were plenty of
customer complaints regarding subpar
manufacturing despite all the
uncertainty though tesla survived 2018
and that was the signal that the time
for evs had to finally come
many big players didn't want to take the
gamble with tesla but now that tesla had
gone to the other side they were willing
to take the risk with other eb startups
and this led them straight to rivien in
february of 2019 amazon led a 700
million dollar investment round for
rivien overnight riven went from
lifetime fundraising of 450 million
dollars to raising 700 million dollars
in a single round and this was just the
beginning just two months later ford
invested 500 million dollars which they
would later raise to 1.2 billion dollars
later that year cox automotive poured in
another 350 million dollars and amazon
would put the nail on the coffin by
ordering 100 000 electric delivery
vehicles from rivien by the end of 2019
ravine had raised a total of 2.85
billion dollars and now that smart money
was in it was time to open up the gates
as we all know starting at the end of
2019 tesla stock soared first it crossed
a hundred billion dollars then overtook
volkswagen and toyota and now it's
literally a trillion dollar company
that's more than the rest of the top 10
auto companies combined i'm not trying
to get into whether that's justified or
not but something that's crystal clear
is the fact that tesla took the rest of
the ev industry with them and that of
course includes rivien
in the meantime it ravine was trying to
start production and get deliveries
going promised delivery dates came and
went and rivian kept delaying the
release time after time but one thing we
can be sure of was that money was no
longer the issue they had already raised
billions and the billions were flowing
in due to tesla hype but rivien was
running out of time
ford had reviewed their f-150 lightning
and tesla was rapidly building their
austin gigafactory and making the cyber
truck a reality
it would have been a shame that riven
had targeted the eevee pickup truck and
suv market a decade ago just to be beat
by tesla and ford luckily for rivien
though they were able to deliver in the
last second at the end of august riven
filed for 80 billion ipo and this
confirmed that rifian was finally ready
to start making deliveries
ironically despite targeting the market
years before ford and tesla it looks
like they only beat them to market by
months
anyway by the time riven ipo'd they had
raised a total of 10.5 billion dollars
since 2019 alone to put that in
perspective it that's half the valuation
of nissan twice the valuation of a mazda
and four times evaluation of ashton
martin and all of that was just to get
their first product to market but
looking back that was just a drop in the
bucket given that they would reach a
valuation of 150 billion dollars which
just leaves one question what's next
the truth is that riven's entire
existence has been a bubble first it was
millions from the government then it was
tens of millions from early investors
then it was hundreds of millions from
smart money and now it's billions from
the public markets it seems like this
must come to an end soon but the truth
is that's not necessarily the case all
it takes is one announcement from elon
that tesla is going to do stocks play on
december 9th and tesla and the ev
industry will go to mars if tesla makes
another one i wouldn't be surprised if
raven ends up overtaking toyota which is
stupid but reality nonetheless
when the bubble does eventually pop
though whether that's tomorrow or after
reaping reaches a trillion dollar
evaluation most regional investors will
likely lose substantial amounts of money
instead of crashing on rivien and
shoring the stock though i think it's a
much better idea to see it in a positive
light the eevee bubble has given
companies that would otherwise have
little chance against the legacy
automakers and opportunity and at the
end of the day the bubble is centered on
a great cause which is reducing
pollution and transitioning to
sustainable energy the more companies
that enter the scene and fight for
market share the faster we'll see a
transition to evs so maybe the bubble
isn't actually all that bad the crash
however will be deadly peruvian if they
don't make a mark before it's too late
so i wish riven the best despite their
stupid valuation but only time will tell
if they're able to make it to the other
side
do you guys think rivien will survive
the eventual crash and rival tesla
comment that down below
also drop a like if you have a love-hate
relationship with the eevee bubble and
of course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one